So I can see the people over here. Just
just a little. Yeah, we'll need Yeah,
that's good. Right there.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in
the book of fasting, the chapter
regarding the pillars of fasting. Now we
mentioned that fasting has two pillars.
intention which we discussed in detail
yesterday and the second pillar
refraining from anything that would
break a person's fast. We mentioned that
there are six things which will break a
person's fast and today inshallah
we want to
u expand
our knowledge on these six things.
So when we say there are six things that
will break a person's fast and we listed
them, each of these six things has
things that
are added to its definition and
things that are excluded from its
definition. And this is what we want to
discuss today. So the first and second
things that would break a person's fast
eating and drinking purposely
the author says
now
eating and drinking
the human being
is linguistically in the Arabic language
language
only known to have eaten something or it
is said that this person has eaten
something if something goes down the
throat. This is the natural
path that food and drink takes and
that's what is in intended when the
scholars of folk say eating or drinking
anything purposely. It doesn't just mean
food. It means anything that takes
the path of food and drink which is the
throat. All right? This is what takes
the path of food and drink.
Whatever it is, whether it's food or
not, the issue is not what is being
eaten or drank. The issue is the act
itself.
So in the Arabic language, you would say
someone ate something or drank something
once it takes the path of the throat
down the esophagus into the stomach.
This is linguistically
what is known as eating or drinking.
What's the difference between eating and
drinking? Nothing. It's just the that
eating is something that's usually solid
or something that is a food and drinking
is something that is liquid. But
ultimately anything that is purposely
swallowed
this is considered to be food or drink
in the definitions of the scholars. So
if that's the meaning of it then why is
it that we say eating and drinking? Why
don't we say swallowing anything? And
the answer is that this is what the
linguists refer to as
This is something that is mentioned
because it is usually
what is swallowed is food or drink. And
so we call it eating or drinking. This
is what is most usually swallowed. But
it's not the only thing that is
swallowed. Person could swallow
medicine. A person could you know
swallow something that is not food right
also a person could inhale something
such as smoke or bahul or cigarette
smoke or whatever it is all of these
things will break a person's fast. Why?
Because they are swallowing it. It is
going down the throat. Now whether it
goes into the lungs or goes into the
stomach, this is inconsequential. What
is meant is that it goes past
the back of the mouth down into the
throat or through the nose down into the
throat. Anything that makes its way down
the throat,
this is what will break a person's fast.
And so from this we have
food or drink obviously we have that
which is taken a nasal
spray for instance this will break a
person's fast
and this isn't something new one
of the ways that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
taught the companions to administer
medicine using black seed is by way of
the nose. This is the most correct way
to administer black seed. we know
that the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam tells us in authentic
narrations that black seed is a cure for
all ailments except for death except for
poison. Right now there are many ways to
take black seed
but the most prominent way in the
prophet's sunnah sallallah.aii wasallam
is that it be taken through the nose
that it be dripped into the nose go
through the sinuses and then down the
throat. This is how the companions
usually would take black seat. But the
scholars mention seven ways to
administer black seed. And the most
prominent of them is through the nose.
This also
and you know eating and drinking that's
not something that really is taken
through the nose. You don't eat or drink
something through the nose. You eat or
drink through the mouth. So how did we
come to the conclusion
that the nose is also a way for a person
to break his fast? Well, there's a
narration in which the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam taught the
companions wudoo
woo. He said in teaching them one of the
companions he said
What is
taking through the nose? It is snorting.
Okay. So he says,"
meaning
be thorough
in
snorting the water for
except if you are fasting.
Now notice this wording here. This
narration is critical because it teaches
us that the nose is a
valid path of food and drink or what
would be considered food and drink for
our intents and purposes. So he's saying
he says and
and exaggerate in
snorting the water for wudoo
unless you are fasting. If you are
fasting then do not. That's what we
understand from the hadith. Except if
you are fasting what's understood
meaning if you're fasting don't
exaggerate in snorting the water for
wudoo. Why? Because it may compromise
your wudoo. That's the only that's the
only understanding of the narration. And
so the scholars cite this narration as
evidence that a person would break his
fast by snorting. Why? Because anything
that is snorted through the nose, it
will it will go down into the throat and
compromise a person's fasting. So then a
question comes up. It's like,
well, if that's the yard stick, then
what about eye drops? Right? And this is
important because the eyes are a kind of
mucous membrane. They produce tears,
they produce and the ducks from the eyes
empty out into the throat, right? So,
, if you were to use eye drops or put
something in your eye, if there's enough
of it, you could taste it or feel it in
your throat. So, is that something that
would break a person's fast eye drops?
And we would say no. It is a very weak
opinion. Some scholars have mentioned it
but it is a very weak argument
that eye drops would break a person's
fast. Why even though it goes through
the throat? Why is it such a weak
argument? Well, it's a weak argument for
a number of reasons. Number one, there's
no mention of it anywhere in the Sunnah.
Imagine with me hundreds, thousands of
companions in Medina, the most rigorous
Muslims that have ever walked this
earth. There there will never be a
generation
of collective of Muslims that care more
about
doing right and avoiding mistakes in
their religion than the companions of
Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam. they will
never exist. They are the most
righteous.
They are the most cautious and they are
the most knowledgeable of any companion
of any prophet or messenger ever.
And we don't have any time in which the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam told them
that this would break their fast. and no
instance in which they asked and no
instance in which they in their fatella
to the following generation told
people that this would break their fast.
So then someone would say well you know
maybe they didn't have eye drops at that
time. That is a very silly argument
because of course they had eye drops in
their time. It may not have been sold by
CVS. It wasn't sold by Walgreens. It
didn't come with a tamperproof
packaging. But yes, they used eye drops.
They used cohul. And not only that, but
it's a type of prophetic medicine.
Who knows one of the most important
things for correcting vision in the
sunnah of Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam.
Tell us
anyone.
Now there is a type of
is
it's a type of stone that is ground
down. It's a very particular type of
stone. It is ground down into a fine
powder. Okay? And there's different
types of it. And often it is used for
beauty, right? It's used to accentuate
the eyes, make the eyes look bigger. But
not always. Some types of are
therapeutic. And in the narration of
Ibah,
he said,
He said,
, I urge you to use
and especially before going to sleep at
night because it
sharpens vision and helps to
and it it also helps to grow out the
eyelashes. It encourages eyelash growth.
Right?
So, elithmid is a very specific type of
rock. Usually, it comes from areas in
North Africa Morocco or
Jeze Algeria, Tunisia, these areas. And
alth you'll know it when you see it
because it is more gray than it is
black. And it looks it has
little it looks it has glitter in
it. That's what it looks when you
when you put it up in the light. It
sparkles almost glitter, but it is
it is gray. It's not this color.
It's gray brother Mox shirt
there. This is
called Elithmid and it's actually it's
pretty expensive, right? I used it for
many years for my eyesight and I can
testify that yes, it is very very good.
I've never had as good eyesight as I did
when I was using althan.
I had actually someone went to
Morocco. I said, "Look, there's Ithmid
there. I need you to bring it for me."
And it was a little little bottle this
big. It was very expensive for me. It
was like $300 at that time. This was
almost 20 years ago. It might as well
have been $3 million for me at that time
because that was a lot of money for me.
And I used it for years and it was very
very good every night before you go to
sleep. And the prophet sallallah.aii was
use it very often. he would use it
three times in the right and two times
in the left. You could go to an
Islamic shop, a Muslim store, what we
used to call them Muslim stores, and
you'll find this kohul in a little box
and it's got, you know, ordo written on
it or Arabic written on it, and it's
called, and you get a big bottle like
this, and it's very jet black, right?
And it actually a lot of these cheap
knockoff have lead in them. So, not only
is that bad for your eyes, but it's
pretty bad for your brain as well.
However, realmid
is very critical part of the
prophet's sunnah. He used it all the
time. And most of the imams of Islam in
those earlier generations and the
companions,
most of his companions, men and women
all used,
right? As a matter of fact, it was so
ubiquitous and so common that Imam Malik
was asked why he doesn't use it because
he didn't used to use alithmat.
And the reason that he didn't use it
wasn't because
you know he wasn't following the
sunnah was because you know of the
general implications at that time. It
was for a different reason. So the point
is is that this is something that was
extremely common place. Could you
imagine the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam in Ramadan. His companions come
to see him during the day of Ramadan and
they have in their eyes and and it would
break their fast and he never says
anything about it. Is that reasonable?
he sees that they're clearly using
while they're fasting in their eyes, but
then he doesn't say anything about it.
He doesn't mention it. He doesn't say
don't do that. this will break your
fast. He never said that. So, we
understand from his silence that it is
something that does not break your fast.
And actually, when you're using alth
when you first put it in, you can
very clearly taste it in your throat. If
you spit, it will come out in your
saliva as well if you put enough. And so
this is something that most of the
companions used, probably all of the
women used and the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam in all of his sunnah in
nine years of fasting Ramadan in
in 14 years of fasting
ashur and other types of fast. And
never once did he mention that this
breaks your fast. But then two 300 years
later we start to say well you know it
would break your fast. Very weak
argument. Very weak. And for this
reason, the majority of scholars do not
hold this opinion that anything
administered to the eye, whether it is
eye drops or kohul or anything else,
whether it's for therapy or it is for
cosmetic purposes. It will not break a
person's fast nor the ear. The ear is
also something that goes into the
throat, right? That's why doctors are
ear nose and throat doctors because
they're all connected there. And
nothing that is administered into the
ear will break a person's fast. Even if
you feel the taste in your throat or
feel something in your throat, it's
very negligible. And this is an
important point and we'll end with this
point and that is that which is
extremely negligible
but
is hard to avoid.
Okay. So Allah describes Islam as
Allah has negated that he has placed any
haraj any undue
or unnecessary
difficulty or inconvenience upon us
in our religion. Right? And so one of
the
types of haraj is something that is
negligible
but it is also very hard to avoid.
This will not break a person's fast like
what so for instance when a person makes
woo
you put the water in your mouth right
and you spit it out. When you spit this
water out, did every last little tiny
tiny tiny tiny microscopic
bit of water come out of your mouth
with that? Huh? Is there any narrations
where he would make wudoo and then spend
the next five minutes spitting to get
everything out? Don't swallow after
making wool for five minutes. Huh? Were
they walking around with cans that they
were spitting in after woo? Right. No.
Why? There is a minuscule an infantismal
amount of water that will invariably
go down a person's throat after making
woo. But it is negligible
and it is almost unavoidable.
You notice the the two the two parts
here not just negligible but also what
unavoidable those two together make al
if we were commanded to avoid that
which is unavoidable and negligible.
This would be the exact definition of
halage, right? Therefore,
that which is negligible
and unavoidable,
this is not counted. Same thing with,
for instance, a person's clothing. If
you were so careful
to never get any kind of neessa on your
clothes, right? But you're living in the
world with people, right? You're sitting
down in a place where a dog could have
sat. You're drinking from a well that
something could have fallen into you.
Right. Is it not conceivable that
there is some slight tiny tiny tiny
amount of neessa involved in that? Yes.
You go into a restroom or you go to use
the restroom and there's tiny tiny tiny
amount of ness that it gets onto your
person or onto this is something which
is
tiny infantismal tiny negligible and it
is almost unavoidable. Therefore, it is
haraj Islam overlooks that right and
from this reasons you'll see in the
fatawa of the scholars
that they do not consider
an inhaler for asthma to break a
person's fast. This will not break a
person's fast. Why didn't we say that
smoking and didn't we say yes but it is
what?
Negligible and it is unavoidable.
Therefore, it is what overlooked.
There is a very big difference between
an inhaler
which it is gaseous but it will become a
liquid when it gets into the throat. You
will taste it, right? But how much of
that
is actually there? Tiny tiny
minuscule amounts.
Less than when you make woo,
right? And it goes into the lungs.
Therefore, it does not break a person's
fast. Very different than smoking.
Smoking is a big amount and it is
avoidable right and it is therefore it
is not a haraj therefore it will break a
person's fast and
so this is a good point to take yes
we'll end with this and show
[Arabic recitation]
their fast for it,
but it doesn't
it is a type of illness. And if a
person had to take a some kind of
liquid form that goes into the stomach
or a person had to take some kind of
pill or something, yeah, it's a valid
reason to break a person's fast. But
just the inhaler as it is, no. Right.
Yes.
Right? So we mentioned the threshold
here is the throat not the mouth not the
nose because both we use to make woo.
For this reason
in his
mentions that tasting does not break a
person's fast.
This is something that companions used
to do. They were cooking whatever. You
go to the market when you you taste
something and then spit it out. This is
fine. And it has the same ruling as
making no different. Same thing with
bah for instance. Let's say I walk
into a room that has bah in it, right?
That's smoke.
And I'm going to taste it in my mouth.
Will it break my woo or break my fast?
No. because it's unintentional
unintentional and it's something that's
being put onto you, right? Contrary to
me lighting bahul and then putting my
thing over it and sucking it in, this
will break a person's woo. The scholars
have noted this specifically as breaking
woo, breaking woo, breaking a person's
fast. Yes.
[Arabic recitation]
mean, you know, we to think we're
special.
Our time, we have so much stuff they
didn't have back then. No, they had most
of it. 99% right now.
[Arabic recitation]
go to inhale a big amount, right? But if
I were to light behold in the masid or
in my room, is that permissible? Yes,
permissible. doesn't break a person's
fast. So, we will stop there inshallah.
We'll continue tomorrow. There's still
more to talk about with regards to
eating and drinking. A whole other
aspect that I didn't get into. We'll
talk about it tomorrow, inshallah.
[Silence]
Yeah, just
right. Good. Thank you.